le film que j'ai sélectionné pour vous c
est dieu créa la femme
le film de 1956 réalisé par roger vadim
pourquoi parce que déjà c'est un film
que j'adore c'est un film mythique qui
est donc la première collaboration entre
roger vadim dans le premier vrai film
long métrage qu'ils ont fait ensemble
avec brigitte bardot
c'est un film aussi qui d'ailleurs a
fait beaucoup scandale aux etats-unis au
moment de sa sortie mais vraiment plus
tard roger vadim a lui même réalisé le
remake america's got fouetter double
peine
est ce que j'adore avec ce film c'est
que particulièrement en ce moment en
confinement mais même plutôt monde année
on a vraiment cette envie de voir des
grands espaces de voir le saint tropez
des années 50-60 se sent trompé qui fait
rêver et cette période mythique avec une
cinématographie et des moments de cinéma
qui sont vraiment exceptionnelles et qui
sont toujours très très beau aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je ne comprends pas quelqu'un c'est
vraiment beau qu'un film mythique qui
aussi a marqué la période est donc c'est
celui que j'ai regardé d'ailleurs il ya
très peu de temps et que j'ai
sélectionné pour vous